We are hearing from folks in the audience
at 6 1 7 8 3 0 47 50.
I see that, Aaron, the trucker is holding
and I want to get caught up with what's going
on with him.
Hey, Aaron, how are things?
Well, pretty much like the last time.
It sounds like you're on the running.
So, yes, of course.
Now, just so you know, since the last time
I called, there have been changes to trucking.
OK.
Anyone who's hauling food or groceries of
any kind.
We are now exempt from our normal regulations.
Wow.
Meaning I can drive pretty much as long as
I want to.
And I although you can tell that the system
wasn't really thought all the way through,
because as I've experienced myself, if your.
Appointment is still an appointment time.
Like a specific time, it's got to be the delivery.
Being able to drive as long as you want isn't
exactly going to help you that much.
All right.
So let me let me make sure I wasn't done all
the way through.
Let me let me make sure I understand that.
So if I understand correctly, a lot of times
the places that you are delivering stuff to
via truck, they have a limited number of loading
docks and things are scheduled out.
So if you are allowed to drive as long as
you want and you show up four hours earlier,
you might still have to wait for hours for
your loading dock to become available.
Is that right?
Exactly.
Mm hmm.
So you can't just show up to wherever you
want to whenever you want to.
Yeah.
Maybe there are some places in the country
we could do that versus simply other places.
Got it.
But it's fair.
It's I suppose it's useful.
I don't know.
But do you think that it's causing drivers
to behave unsafely, being able to drive as
long as they want?
I mean, aside from the one article I read
last night of ACARS, the driver who drove
it to a lake because he fell asleep behind
the wheel, so far it seems like most truckers
are actually using their brains.
Yeah, and behaving in a way that is somewhat
intelligent.
Right.
Oh, for the most part, no.
Now, speaking of using your brain, let's leave
it to my question.
Now I consider you the most levelheaded person
on the block.
I don't yeah.
I don't consider myself to be on the list.
I consider myself.
Because one thing I want to ask you, because
I trust you to give the fairest answer to
this question, please.
Everybody thinks that they know what the problem
with America.
I don't.
I have no delusions of grandeur.
I know.
I don't know much.
All I can give you are the things the way
I the way I see it.
The biggest problem with America is that the
American people have put too much of their
responsibility to think on the government
and not on themselves.
Which might explain the reason why so many
people rely on mainstream media to basically
tell them what the thing.
I don't agree with that.
I feel like people should think for themselves.
My question is I can only justify being outraged
and putting in all of its energy to care about
other people for so long.
Obviously, Trump wasn't the trigger that finally
made people wake up and it's starting to look
like the Corona virus and all of the nonsense
that goes around with rotavirus is going to
be the trigger that gets people to wake up.
Right.
So my question to you is.
In your own words, if you even can, which
I wouldn't be surprised.
How do I justify continuing to care about
other Americans when other Americans don't
seem to care enough about themselves?
So let me give you here's a kid.
This is beautiful.
Let's imagine that you're not empathetic.
You don't care about other people.
You're just concerned with yourself.
You should still act in a way that accounts
for other people because you live in a world
of seven billion people.
And unless you are literally going to isolate
yourself in the northwest territories of Canada,
trapping mink and living off of frozen berries.
Your life is going to be better or worse based
on what other people are doing and how other
people are doing.
So you can take a complete say, like I don't
care about other people beyond how it affects
me.
You live in a society, and if things are worse
off for everybody, they're going to be worse
off for you as well.
So from even even if you're just selfish,
we still need to care about other people.
Oh, sure.
I guess that's not.
I mean, I would I don't want to keep you too
long because you have thousands of people
want to talk to you.
But I would just say up until this point,
my life is pretty much unaffected by the Corona
virus.
My life continued as normal.
And I'm just getting to a point now where
I believe in helping those who help themselves.
Call me conservative.
I don't care.
Well, I believe in helping those who help
themselves.
And if Americans are going to continue to
sit down and allow all of these people with
all of this power to just continue to do whatever
the hell they want, then I just can't continue
to justify having all of this anger and all
of the outrage at the things that happen to
me.
I'm sorry if that makes me a bad person, but
I guess I'm a bad person.
It makes you a terrible person, Aaron.
That's exactly right.
It makes you a terrible person.
Listen, I think I understand your perspective.
But before you go, I just have two other trucking
questions for you.
If I may.
OK.
I know you don't do this because you said
last time you don't, but what do other truckers
use to stay awake into the night?
Is it caffeine?
Does it?
Is it caffeine pills?
Does it escalate into other stimulants?
What do people use for staying awake while
driving?
I've seen everything you can imagine.
People some people see people drink for Monster
Energy drinks, which I highly don't recommend.
Other people chew gum, which is something
I've taken up again.
It varies, but most of the time it's stimulant
is mostly energy drinks.
Got it.
OK.
And last question.
My high school physics teacher drove trucks
on the weekends and said many truckers carry
guns because some of the loading dock areas
are unsafe, but that he doesn't.
In your experience, what percentage of long
haul truckers are carrying guns?
In my experience, I would say less than 1
percent.
You're laughing.
Oh, look at these days.
Yes.
The thing is, most places these days will
tell you shipper and receiver guns are not
allowed.
I'm from God.
Obviously, the don't ask, don't tell type
of deal.
Because unless they're gonna search your old
truck, they're not going to know.
But in my experience, less than 1 percent.
Less than 1 percent.
Got it.
All right.
Araby Reese.
Be safe out there.
I appreciate the call.
Take care of space-based.
All right.
We'll see you there.
There is Aaron, the trucker.
Great to hear from him